4 000 of these i can give you the best  play in the world and then you know best  training best nutrition but if you don't  show up it doesn't matter right right  okay cool so the reason that we have  such a high success rate your three  forms of accountability one is that you  have peer-to-peer accountability other  people are gonna be starting with who  are in the same spot as you next you  have alumni accountability so people  further ahead of you are gonna be  pulling you and cheering you ahead  because they've done it and then you've  got expert accountability from the  coaches who've done this 100 times and  the last one and the most important one  people basically make a bet on  themselves and so you pay 500 you do  everything you hit the goal we'll give  you the whole thing back pretty much the  explanation